I'd like to take a minute to give you a
visual of why the distributive property
works the way that it works. So, let's go
back to drawing our beautiful circles. So
let's say we have a group of 2 circles
and also a group of 10 circles. And,
according to this equation, what we're
going to want to do is both add them
together and then triple them. So if we
were to solve this problem the first way
that we talked about, we would do this
addition inside the parentheses first, and
then our multiplication. So you would take
these two groups, the 2 and the 10
circles, and merge them into one group.
Great. So now we have 12 circles in one
big group. And then, the next thing I want
to do is multiply this group by 3, so
that means we want 3 sets of this
group of circles. So right now, we have
one set and I can add 1 more, which make
it 2 sets and then I can add a third
one. Remember, multiplication is just
repeated addition. So now, I have 3
groups of these 12 circles together and
that's it. I can count these up and if I
decide, I'd do that right now, which I
won't, because I'm lazy, we would see that
we have 36 circles. Okay, great. So,
that's the first method for solving this
problem. However, we also have that 2nd
method of solving problems like this and
that's using the distributive property. So
if we want to use the distributive
property, then the first step is going to
be to multiply each of the terms that's
inside the parentheses by the 3. So
let's write down method 2. First, we're
going to say 3 times 2, then we're going to add
that to 3 times 10, just like we saw in the last
quiz. Starting with the group of two
circles, I wanted to triple this like we
see in this 1st term. And then, as we
see in the 2nd term, I want to triple
this group as well. Great. So now I have
two groups, one group of 6 circles which
is 3 times 2, and one group of 30 circles which
is 3 times 10.
And then, I want to add those two groups
together. So we need to merge this set of
circles with this set of circles, and we
end up with the exact same picture that we
got using the first method. Once again, we
have 36 circles all in one group. I hope
this has given you some insight into why
we're allowed to distribute multiplication
to terms that are added together inside a
parentheses.